Transcriptor: Adriel Isay Pacheco
Revisor: Emanuel Restituyo Gil
¿Qué pasa cuando un barrio en Quito
integra la ciudad y a la naturaleza
para garantizar derechos?
La Constitución de Ecuador es única
en el mundo por garantizar
el derecho a la ciudad en su artículo 31,
y derechos de la naturaleza
en su artículo 71.
Como estudiantes de la
Facultad Para La Ciudad, Arquitectura y
Paisaje, en conjunto con la escuela de
Gestión Ambiental, nos preguntamos:
¿Cómo puede este marco legal nacional
aplicarse en escala local y barrial?
Pensamos en un barrio y centralidad
que busque derecho a la ciudad
con justicia ambiental.
Específicamente en Quitumbe.
Una zona sistemáticamente marginalizada en
el sur de la capital ecuatoriana.
El derecho a la ciudad, consiste en
la suma de muchos derechos urbanos.
Es decir, derecho a la vivienda,
a la centralidad, al espacio público,
a la movilidad,
la educación, al cuidado, trabajo digno,
al ocio, recreación, a la salud,
a la cultura y a la soberanía alimentaria.
Nuestra propuesta para la centralidad
incluye equipamientos que garanticen
estos derechos gratuitamente, como
parques, vivienda social, cooperativa,
guarderías, hospitales y otros.
El derecho de la ciudad nos muestra que
estos equipamientos y derechos
se refuerzan mutuamente y no pueden ser
comprendidos de manera aislada.
El derecho a la ciudad también habla
de la participación ciudadana
en la producción del espacio,
por lo que estos equipamientos
no pueden ser pensados
desde arriba hacia abajo,
sino que, al contrario,
los vecinos y vecinas
deben participar
en su diseño e implementación.
El sur de Quito tiene una larga historia
de organización barrial de la cual
el resto de la ciudad puede aprender.
En general, debemos mirar hacia barrios
como Quitumbe, que a pesar de tener muchos
desafíos debido a años de olvido estatal,
también tienen
muchas cosas que enseñarnos.
Por ejemplo, la minga, una práctica
ancestral que se refiere a una forma de
trabajo colectivo, ha permitido la
recuperación comunitaria de quebradas
en la zona de Quitumbe.
Otro ejemplo es la vivienda incremental,
que consiste en la construcción y
ampliación gradual de una vivienda a
través del tiempo, considerando el
presupuesto y tamaño de familia.
La propuesta urbana considera y reinventa
esta práctica constructiva de diseño
incremental que está muy presente
en Quitumbe y en el sur de Quito.
A pesar de estos desafíos, Quitumbe es
un barrio de uso mixto.
Las personas caminan más y usan más el
transporte público,
tienen menos carros y por lo tanto tienen
una menor emisión de CO2 per cápita
que el promedio de la ciudad.
La propuesta urbana potencia estas
fortalezas presentes en el barrio,
ampliando espacios para peatones,
ciclovías y transporte público
a base de energía eléctrica.
La cosmovisión indígena en Sudamérica
interpreta la vida en relación armoniosa
entre seres humanos y la Pachamama
o madre naturaleza.
Este entiende al agua, aire, sol
y tierra como bienes comunes.
La propuesta considera los ciclos de
estos elementos, en equipamientos
comprendidos como flujos naturales
que son parte del metabolismo urbano,
incluyendo ciclos del
reciclaje y residuos.
Del compostaje y soberanía alimentaria.
Ciclos de servicios básicos como
el agua y de la energía.
La zona de Quitumbe incluye un amplio
ecosistema de quebradas andinas.
A pesar de que el derecho a la ciudad
sirve como un marco
para garantizar el bienestar humano.
Muchas veces ha ignorado el hecho de
que las ciudades son parte
de naturalezas urbanas
y ecosistemas más amplios.
Debido a esto, la propuesta repiensa
la ciudad como hábitat de todo ser vivo,
en donde la arquitectura y el barrio
forman parte del ecosistema.
El derecho a la ciudad, por lo tanto, debe
incluir a seres humanos y no humanos
y debe garantizar los derechos de la
naturaleza amparados en la constitución
del Ecuador.
Los barrios y las quebradas de Quito no
deben entenderse de manera aislada,
sino dentro de un mismo ecosistema,
porque al fin y al cabo, las ciudades
la naturaleza siempre están conectadas.